Little
Mermaid now I know if there's people in
here who were upset that little mermaid
was black that's just dumb mermaids
aren't
real she made them songs
[Music]
better I was like giddy girl that wasn't
the problem the problem was her father
was
Spanish just have a black family Under
the
Sea why couldn't this just be the black
neighborhood and then it gets worse and
then you you have just Spanish father
and then you meet her sisters Asian girl
Indian girl two white girls a black girl
one girl was in a wheelchair she under
to se like this don't even make sense
how the this dad was getting it
in he had a side piece in the Indian
Sea he was in the Atlantic
Ocean it didn't make no sense